[Music]
hello
there's widespread support for one
feminist claim that gender should not
have a defining role
in creating social hierarchies and some
go further
arguing that gender is a social
construct that should be eradicated
yet at the same time many want many
people want to identify
positive female traits that they want to
promote
so is it hypocritical to be proud of
aspects of one's gender identity
at the same time as claiming to want to
get rid of the social distinction
altogether must we choose between these
two
seemingly contradictory claims or can we
retain
and even celebrate gender identity while
at the same time
campaigning to get rid of it tough
questions but very important ones and i
think we've got three fantastic speakers
here to debate the issues
today let me introduce them to you first
of all eileen miles
is a prolific writer of poetry plays
fiction
non-fiction and theater pieces and they
have been leading
voice in progressive gender politics for
the last
30 years bianca jagger is a
human rights civil liberties peace
social justice and environmental
protection campaigner
and she is founder and president of the
bianca jagger
human rights foundation which she
established in 2005
to be a force for change and a voice for
the most vulnerable
and nina power is a cultural critic and
social commentator so i'm going to start
this is our habit here at the festival
with asking each of our speakers to give
us three minutes in which they'll
introduce their take
on the starting question that question
is the uh is the uh the starkly put
uh question of should we seek to
eradicate
gender and to start us off could i ask
you to join us eileen miles
hi um yeah i think i mean i
of course i think it's just the wrong
question all together um
i think um i mean there's two there's
two things that came to mind
when i looked at it though and also the
focus on female seems
unnecessary um there's two things i've
encountered lately or
have been um evolving towards and one is
um
one is a book i read recently by a
friend of mine that's forthcoming
um their name is so mayor and they're a
british
i believe academic and writer and
thinker
and they've written a terrific book
called um
a nazi word for a nazi thing and what
they're talking about
is um is the um the famous book burning
in berlin um at the beginning of another
in the 30s and that that known or
unknown that most of those
when we talk about it's usually talked
about as a kind of a
you know in the states like a first
amendment thing or a destruction of um
of freedom or experimentation but in
fact it was very specifically a library
of of um sexual knowledge and
information
and um um queerness and
and um you know just the multitudes of
all the sexual
information and positions and that were
that were
data that was available at that time and
so um
in effect and what's i think it's so
interesting that they what they
basically
um and it was categorized as we know
famously as
um in degeneracy and
um degenerate art degenerate knowledge
and what i think the german word for
degeneracy
means without category without gender
um upholding fixity and it's it's you
know it's it's intriguing
that um fascist governments
dictatorships and
certainly presently um thinking of of
putin
thinking of donald trump thinking of um
both scenario are all coming down
passionately against queers
and trans people and it's sort of like
it it it just kind of um begs the
question of what is this obsession with
wanting to keep genders in position and
and and um as if that were protecting
the state you know and
with what that means i think it just
comes down to
you know like kind of keeping supposedly
men with dicks out of women's bathrooms
and there's this kind of
projection of reapiness on to trans
people
you know and all you know and um which
seems to me to remind me of you know
like just kind of a
just a cool way in the patriarchy of
marriage being an institution
created to protect women from being
raped by
other men so that they can be raped by
this man
and also you know with i mean like right
now we're in a terrible state
um because what we all feel as um
american um i ideally trans feminists
is that uh the female the right
the right for the female body to have
power and agency
is about to be taken away or tr or
assault
that that you know our government would
s because
but again again it's sort of like the
whole question of
why there's such a core need for say
when um when a man has placed semen
inside of a female
female body that it must stay there that
all acts of masculinity
are permanent and inherent you know
again it seems like another kind of
reification
of gender and its fixity so thanks very
much indeed for stepping forward those
points so clearly and thanks also for
reminding us of
that uh terrifying nazi term and arta
kunst the degenerate art which of course
uh
had uh tremendous destructive power uh
in the in the 1930s
i'm going to turn if i may immediately
to uh
bianca jagger bianca welcome and could i
ask you if you could
address that sort of central question
should we be seeking to
eradicate gender
thank you no
i am not uh advocating
that we should eradicate gender let me
be clear and concise
i am a human right
defender i have spent my life
my adult life defending the right
of women and girls if i
made um just simply
go to some facts from the un
that are critical
for me and for many women perhaps this
debate is a debate
that is taking place in the developed
world
so i know about the existential
um battle that women are facing
throughout the world today especially
during the pandemic
when um sexual violence
and domestic violence has increased
under when
women are lives in many places
including right here in the uk are at
stake
but let me say something from the
equality between men and women was a
core tenant
enshrined in the u.n charter in 1945
yet 75 years later women and girls live
in a world of widespread gender
inequality turning this iran is a
priority of the un
in 2020 and of the bianca jagger human
rights foundation
as well um which also marks
the 25th anniversary of the beijing
declaration and platform for action
the 20th anniversary of security council
resolution
1325 on women peace and security
on the 5th anniversary of the
sustainable development goals
the 2030 agenda is clear
gender equality and the empowerment of
all women and girls
is a goal in itself sustainable
development goal 5
as well as catalyst for the achievement
on all
of the other goals ultimately
equality to both women and men the world
has
a decade left to turn this promise into
action
although it is 40 years since the
adoption
of the conventional form of
discrimination against women
discrimination remains commonplace in
law
and practice but it is five billion
women and girls
live in countries with at least one
discriminatory law
on the books these statutes restrict
women's ability
abilities to make decisions about
marriage divorce
child custody and to make choices about
getting a job or starting a business
we have seen as i have said the threat
to women during the lockdown
this is an issue of life and death for
many of these women
i am not going to get into a debate
whether we should eliminate
gender but how we achieve gender
equality
i am a human rights defender
a human rights offender of women and
girls
during the lockdown we have seen what is
called intimate terrorism
intimate terrorism that is performed
these women
because many of the social services
today
are not up to being able to help them
because they are with those that torture
them
they are forced to be inside the house
so for me the real debate here is
what can we do to protect women
what can we do to create gender equality
um in cities across across the world
we are seeing how this is increasing
we've seen an increase on on marriage
of of of child
um girls we're seeing an increase on
f dm we see fgm
we're seeing an increase on on family
seed
germicide i think that this is the real
issue we see that in order to achieve
a gen um a gender pay gap it will take
us a hundred years
and know i want to be a woman i want to
defend
the rights of women and girls thank you
very much
thank you very much for a urgently put
extremely clear setting out of the
agenda and we'll be returning to you in
just a few minutes to continue the
discussion and debate thank you for that
but before we do that we should turn
to our third opening statement which
will come to us from nina power nina
yeah thank you i think to continue
watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you